start off with the what well what's the
mood like at this conference currently
in this conference in a representative
of a three different countries like us
japan and the china getting theatre and
exchanging all the information in the
you know opinions and the two to provide
a even better innovation from the
community that's a kind of in a purpose
of this conference
okay you know what are the what are the
buzzwords that you're hearing there
what's what's the big story coming what
is the big story coming out there in
your view at this moment i or T internet
/ things would be the big weddings
because you know so many companies in
three regions or providing the new
service innovative services from
different perspective from us you know
we see a lot of it on internet company
is offering you know a big platform type
of services for IOT and in this country
Japan of the government is leading to
provide the innovative service from the
industry in terms of IOT especially for
the electric power meet smart meter
world and in China i know many different
industries are looking for the
opportunities of IOT and the data very
aggressively to provide a new business
model a new service model so i can enjoy
in or three big countries different
strategies and the different movement
Takeshi said like you mentioned internet
of things iot also got drones virtual
reality machine learning Bitcoin etc
which is in your which are you most
excited about actually you know they are
you know appearing appeal and apparently
you know the bleep virtual reality or
entertainment perspective all very
emphasize but in the reality the you
know improvement of efficient shield is
a big big millet of this IOT for example
you know if we can put the you know
communication capability to all the
machines in the older production value
chain then you know we can monitor which
machines are providing what kind of
value precisely and we can reform all
the product lines to more efficient ones
so this is kind of you know not so
exciting but very you know a powerful
efficiency improvements who do come from
the dis IOT movement i believe ya
education selling one more thing which
i'm sure might be a buzzword as wearable
technology to your not being a great fan
of the launch of the are the Apple watch
what do you want to see what's gonna
products do you think are gonna be
making it big there when it comes to
wearables
I think I you know wearable devices
would be a kind of in your transition
product but I mean transition product is
you know supreme purpose of wearable
capability is you know to make our
brains to communicate to the internet
more easily our easier or more simply
and the Supreme perspective is you know
to provider communication capability
into my brain but they're at this moment
you know technologically medical
technology cannot provide that kind of
capability so we have to use some
devices like glasses or watch or any
kind of a no devices future is you know
closer to the human body other wearable
machines to communicate to the internet
but they I think you know by taking a 20
next 20 years surely you know the new
type of devices like chipset will be
developed and if I put the chip into my
plane then y'know I can communicate to
the internet without having any kind of
devices that kind of dream to come to
the real world within 20 years so
wearable devices will be a kind of inner
transition trivial solution to make the
dream world come true